now i'm crazy nobody does that try
different things i'm gonna try my car
i'm gonna try outside and then you see
if it works this gives you the data to
make better decisions if you're capable
if you're an expert if you've got ideas
in here that can change people's lives
do not cut yourself short long videos
crush it will change your entire channel
man first i want to give a quick shout
out to all of the amazing staff the team
here sean everybody behind can we give
them a round of applause it's been such
an awesome event right
[Music]
second i want to give you guys a shout
out because when i first started my
channel i would have been way too afraid
to come to something like this
you may not believe it by the energy and
everything how i show up but i'm an
introverted person
i'm naturally shy
but it's the
desire to serve that gets me out of my
comfort zone and the courage to show up
and do this
and hopefully some of you guys can
connect and resonate with that
appreciate you guys
today i was asked to do something a
little more on the advanced side so
we're going to talk about five advanced
youtube strategies that i've used to
generate over half a billion views
but i know a lot of you guys are still
in the early phases so before diving
into those strategies i wanted to share
a quick
overview of kind of where i started
and i'm just going to pull up my website
here and this is my journey
so unlike maybe some of the stories that
you guys have seen of like rapid growth
and expansion and we're crushing it and
killing it i really struggled in the
early days of youtube so i started in
2009 you can see
my first year in 25 subscribers
107 subscribers i'm in year five and i
got what two thousand subscribers
right so it took me a long time to get
going and a lot of that was just me
getting out of my own way me trusting
myself me believing that i had a message
to share
me believing that i was good enough me
believing that you know an introvert
could get in front of the camera and
share a message and so some people end
up printing this off and putting it by
their wall and then they uh they dm me
and say i'm beating you evan
so if you you know if you're on year two
in your journey and you have more than
107 subscribers you're ahead of me
so you can use that as some inspiration
to help you grow your channel and it's
really just people ask me when they see
this the number one question i get asked
is well how did you keep going
you know like how did you keep going
when it wasn't working out it's great to
see the three million whatever right now
but how did you keep going
and the answer for me was it's always
about serving
so it was never about what i don't have
it was always a focus on who i am
serving right now
and we tend to always focus on what we
don't have yet right like why am i not
at a thousand subs or ten thousand subs
or a hundred thousand subs or a million
or like whatever the next step is for
you
where if you focus on who you are
serving right now
one you're a lot happier
you know two the people who you are
serving they'll take you to the people
who you're not serving yet
and it also gives you the momentum and
the energy and encouragement to keep
going
everybody in this room
has watched a video on youtube
and it inspired them inspired you to
make some kind of shift right you've all
watched some video from somebody on
youtube that then inspired you to make
some kind of shift
and that's what i see in this room
you guys have the ability to be that
person for somebody else
and default to assuming that if 40
people watched your video
we all we all we always think oh 40
people that sucks right
assume that for one out of those 40
people this was the life-changing
message that they needed to hear
and if you can remember that while
you're in the filming process
it changes everything
because we're so focused on how well we
look and how good our microphone and
camera and the setup and all that is
if you focus and said on i'm going to
make something today that's going to
change somebody's life
maybe not a million people but one
person who's watching this video
they're going to have their life changed
because you showed up that day
you like that
it just changes how you show up because
it's same thing for me i'm backstage oh
my god all these people
my goal is for one person here
that this talk becomes the shift for you
and if you can remember that instead of
thinking about the pimple on your face
or how your hair
isn't done properly this takes a long
time every morning to get ready
right when we're focused on ourselves we
play small when you focus on others and
how that message might serve it gives us
the courage to go off and do something
much bigger things that you never
thought would be possible evan in 2009
would never say that i'd be here
never
and so i hope that you guys learned some
of the strategies today from me from the
other speakers
and maybe one of you are going to be on
stage at the next girl with video live
coming up
right
so i've got five advanced strategies
that i want to share for those of you
who are at the early stages don't stress
out don't freak out if it's kind of
overwhelming i'm going to try to go fast
through them
but get the recording you can record
with your cell phone if you want
especially the last one
record it because people then always
come up to me and say hey why did you do
that thing at the end again it's like
did you record it no but can you show me
again so record the last session
especially okay tip number one
we need to be testing our old videos
updating the thumbnails and titles on
our old videos if you have any kind of
catalog of videos in your youtube
account right now the single greatest
opportunity is to be split testing the
thumbnails and titles we're so focused
on what's next and we don't do enough
testing of what has come
right now we launch one main video every
day on my main channel
and we have an internal goal to split
test 100 videos every day
from our back catalog
100 new split tests on thumbnails every
day now i'm crazy nobody does that right
i've got four people on my team and
they're just dedicated to doing that
completely but the single biggest
opportunity if you have any size channel
with content on it the biggest
opportunity for garyvee for sean for
alex hermosie for vanessa lao for pat
flynn for evan carmichael is to split
test your old content
this is an example
when i was doing this i told youtube
it's like dude this is crazy can we do a
case study on you
and so they wrote this up as a case
study on me for split testing we took a
video here
this video was done in 2016.
we split tested it changed the thumbnail
in 2020.
now first off
this video in 2020 would still get me
100 views a day
a four-year-old video was still getting
me views 100 views a day no that's not
insane
but you're not getting that on any other
platform right nobody cares about your
instagram your tick tock your twitter
your facebook your linkedin your
anything from a week ago let alone four
years ago so if you're trying to build a
brand that lasts
youtube has to be the game for you
so this video was doing 100 views a day
all we did was split test the thumbnail
we changed the thumbnail around and bang
it pops to up to fifteen thousand views
a day on a four-year-old video that i
did nothing else to change a thumbnail
fifteen thousand views a day
at the time when they finished this case
study it added an extra nine hundred
thousand views to the channel just as
one video by updating the thumbnail
people ask me
what's a good click-through rate
you ever thought that or you asked
somebody what's a good click-through
rate
that's not a great question to ask let
me show you why
when you first launch a video and it
just goes out to your hardcore
subscribers right people who love you do
we expect a high or lower click-through
rate
right higher
if a video pops and blows up and it's
going people who've never heard of you
brand new people who are trying to bring
into our community with that video to
strangers have a higher or lower
click-through rate
right
so the more your video is getting out to
new people the lower your click-through
rate goes because we're reaching new
people
the best video on your channel by views
should have among the lowest
click-through rates on your channel
my best video has i don't know 18
million views probably has like a two
percent click-through rate
that's not bad
so what's a good click-through rate
it really depends on the impressions
that you're getting
so if you're going to be doing analytics
on your videos one of the most important
things to test to look at how do you
decide which thumbnails or which videos
to test next
look at impression categories
now we've gotten so sophisticated in
this that we developed our own tool to
do it this isn't something i'm selling
or is available but it's something that
we use because we're just so obsessed
with doing split tests
if you look at this category for example
this is one to five million
impressions
so over the past 90 days these videos
got one to five million impressions
those are good to compare against each
other and you can find this data in
youtube studio as well just look at the
past 90 days
look at the impressions and then see how
well the videos are doing
so if we look at this category as an
example this video here has 1.7 million
impressions and a 2.3 click-through rate
if i scroll down we see this one here
this one's doing well elon musk talking
about weed
there we go
has a million impressions and seven
percent click-through rate
similar number of impressions reaching
the same number of people but a vastly
different click-through rate
these videos are worth comparing to each
other seven percent versus 2.3 percent
is a big difference
we need to go and fix these videos
right so in this scenario in the one to
five million impressions
having a 2.3 click-through rate is bad
we need to go in and fix it
and we might work on that thumbnail 50
times
it loses it's still unperforming do it
again test again test again test again
test again and for anybody who's been in
marketing for any amount of time if
you're running paid ads if you're doing
landing pages you always test the title
the subtitle the copy the ad but for
every reason when we go to youtube we
forget about it
so what's a good click-through rate
go to your impressions look at the past
90 days see which videos have similar
number of impressions and then the ones
that have the lowest click-through rate
that's what you want to test
and for anybody who's got team here
that's the highest use of their time
because you get in front of the camera
takes up the most time
this will really help you with getting
suggested views
suggested for most of you should be the
game that you're playing
we were strict on our tool we don't even
allow split testing in the first week
because the first seven days is going to
your core audience i want you to be able
to reach a new audience
so if you are in my expertise is thought
leadership education so if you're in
thought leadership education this is
exactly for you if you're making slime
channels or something that may not be as
direct to fit
i can still help but i'm not as the
expert for that but thought leadership
education
this works
if suggested is not your number one
source of traffic
your channel should be three to five
times bigger
think about how people find the video
they'll come in they might search for
something cool you can rank and search
but then people don't go back to the
search page
they go see all the other videos that
are down the side or at the bottom and
suggested
so the ranking goal becomes not to rank
in search but to rank and suggested
so if search your browser your number
one traffic source and you're in
education thought leadership your
channel should be three to five times
bigger
just by focusing on suggested and easy
way to do that is to split test your
thumbnails and titles
these are videos right now that youtube
is trying to promote on my channel but
people are not clicking
so i'm losing
i need to fix that
so if you have any kind of archive
content you don't have to be doing a
hundred split tests today that's crazy
nobody does it
but look at your old videos
even ones that are performing
a lot of people are afraid of split
testing their top 20 videos
i did it
it works
if the title or thumbnail underperforms
the video will end up going back to
where it was and if you get a higher
click-through rate on your thumbnail
title it ends up crashing
it's scary when you've got a video with
millions of views you don't want to
touch it
i'm not telling you to touch it
but it worked for me
so that's a huge opportunity okay so
number one we're gonna split test look
at all of our videos and update our
thumbnails and titles
okay number two
seventy percent audience retention at
one minute
obsess over it every video has what
looks like this it's an audience
retention curve you guys know audience
retention curve
yeah cool
70 at one minute
70 at one minute
if you can hit 70 at one minute people
will watch the rest of it
they'll stick with you people have a
short attention span yes for the first
minute if you hook them they'll keep
watching most people in my category
thought leadership entrepreneurship
education those started videos like hey
guys welcome back it's me evan wow happy
what day yesterday wednesday thursday i
don't even know tuesday welcome back to
my channel like welcome back who are you
like you want to be targeting people who
don't know who you are yet right so when
you say welcome back i don't know who
you're talking to
you have to lead with a hook you lead
with a powerful opinion make me want to
watch past the 70 mark and this is where
you can make objective decisions as
opposed to subjective ones right when
people say man i don't know i have a
great intro it's fire i've got energy
like okay cool let's pull up your graph
like that sucks
right where are we at one minute here
you know i don't know 30 percent
it doesn't mean you suck like doesn't
mean you suck this is where we struggle
like it's not performing we didn't do a
good job therefore we internalize like
we suck no you don't suck you're awesome
that you even tried
but it
sucks like objectively this video sucks
it should be redone right now you can't
go back and edit this one but for future
ones when you're going to try something
you pay attention to that first minute
if you can hold them for the first
minute they'll you have to really screw
up to lose them afterwards
so it's usually that first minute where
people are really really really really
struggling
so this is where
you get a couple days data in
go back look at the video and see how
that first minute did
and try something and document it's like
okay this time i'm going to try x
this time i'm going to try something new
this i'm going to try
you know dancing i don't say just how
i'm going to try a powerful opinion this
i'm going to try to leave with a
question this i'm going to try leading
with an opinion i've got this i'm going
to try right you try different thing i'm
going to try my car i'm going to try
outside and then you see if it works
this gives you the data to make better
decisions
obsess over this like there's so much
data in youtube analytics that you can
you can get lost it's a amazing tool
that i could spend weeks in and i love
it but for most of you you don't have to
worry about that but you have to obsess
over this
the audience retention curve aim for 70
at one minute it will change your entire
channel
okay so that's number two
number three
this is where we might
blow a couple minds or get a little
controversial
i want you to make
longer videos
longer videos
inside of thought leadership education
at least make longer videos at least try
it
there's nothing necessarily wrong with
shorts we can go into a whole different
panel on shorts
but think about the problem that you're
trying to solve for people if you're
actually helping people
when they're struggling to learn
something
where are they going to go i met a
doctor here a neurologist i don't know
who's in the room there's a neurologist
here who was making areas making videos
helping people with epilepsy
right so he stopped me in the hallway
talking about epilepsy said cool what's
your what's your best video of all time
on the channel it's like us this video
where i talk about medication a certain
kind of medication for epilepsy awesome
how long is that video four minutes long
cool you got to go longer
if somebody walked in like think about
it if somebody walked in and i asked
them somebody walked into his office and
they were concerned about if i walk in
my mom has epilepsy my sister has
epilepsy i'm i'm struggling right like
what do i do i walk into his office and
ask him about what i should do how about
this medication like are you only gonna
talk for four minutes about that
life-changing medication he's like no
i'm gonna answer the questions i'm gonna
be there i'm gonna help them cool do
that for your eyes
make a longer video
if somebody cares about
epilepsy and that drug
where are they gonna go to get the
information
the library
right like where they gonna go
they're going to youtube when they're
finding people like him experts
you're actually cheating people out of
the opportunity to learn
so go longer
if you want to win and suggested
go longer
youtube is promoting long videos
i used to recommend so then well how
long how long should it be i used to
recommend 10 minutes plus that was
always a default 10 minutes plus 10
minutes plus we're seeing the highest
growth category in the one to three hour
category
one to three hours
if you have something to say
right if he's gonna talk about epilepsy
and just go in circles and ramble and
repeat himself 80 times don't do that
but assuming you actually know what
you're talking about
go longer
suggested videos will make you more
money will convert better to subscribers
we'll have an average watch time it's
way higher will convert better to people
signing up for your products and
services if you compare it to a short
and i'm not anti short just if you had a
choice
you go along
because somebody watching a 40 second
video of you versus somebody spending an
hour with you is a completely different
relationship
now you may not be able to make hour
long videos cool don't stress but don't
feel like you have to cut yourself short
if you have podcasts go longer how did
rogan blow up three hour podcasts
go longer if you can
this eddie this guy is eddie pinero
you're world within i don't know if
anybody knows eddie or his father
we got some eddie fans cool so eddie's
been a friend for a while i spoke at his
event and his biggest videos where he's
really he does motivational videos
where he'll speak that he'll he'll he'll
yell into the microphone and i'll get
you all hyped up his best videos were
three minutes long like that video this
video here on the side the number one
video is a three minute video and it's
what six years old okay 2.3 million
views 6 years old said eddie
go longer
i want to see a one hour video
evan you don't understand i make these
short clips short motivational videos
nobody's going to sit there and watch a
one hour video you don't understand my
audience cool
try one hour video
and he posted it and he's got two up on
here
now all of his recent stuff is all is
all long look at this one here so here
uh no this one here
rise best motivational video compilation
nine months ago 1.5 million views
three
hours long
okay how about we go down a little bit
more what you watch that
okay
five months ago this is your time 1.3
million views
three hours long
two hours and 59 57 minutes
so if we look at some of these if you
look at these so all of this new stuff
by the way is all longer like you can't
always go three hours but they're all
10 12 45 50 hour half
because people will watch
and youtube loves recommending videos
and people are watching it right they
love the long form stuff so
if we look at these two videos right 1.5
million views and 1.6 million views
these two back to back
a three hour video versus a four minute
video
this was nine months ago this took six
years to get to 1.6 million views so
about the same number of views
if you want to talk about making money
on a video the difference between a
three hour video 1.5 million views
and a four minute video 1.6 million
views is dramatically different
dramatic this changed his life
but then people going to his event
people hiring him to speak people hiring
him to coach if you spend three hours
with somebody they're much more likely
to want to work with you than a quick
little clip so it's not it may not be
possible for everybody
but i would at least try it
and so my challenge to the good doctor
was how often you're making videos he's
like once a week cool
four five six minutes long cool
keep doing that
for june keep doing that and find a way
to make
four one hour videos on a topic that you
care a lot about too and just test it
and it would shock me if those videos
were not your best performing videos not
out of the gate
because we're playing for suggested
that's the game
30 60 90 120 days out those would be the
best videos for your channel the most
watched time the most subscribers gain
the most newsletter signups the most
customers asking for you the most
revenue from adsense all of it
if you're capable if you're an expert
you've got ideas in here that can change
people's lives do not cut yourself short
long videos crush
okay number four i want to show you
quickly how to how to find good topics
for videos because our game is suggested
not search
right this is how you do it
you type in a topic that you would care
about so um the zen domain here is is in
the audience and he's a confidence coach
so i typed in here how to be confident
so you think about the title that you
would come up with how to be confident
and you could make a video on that right
zane
zayn
cool
we're not going to call it that though
that's not a good title
the game is not ranking for how to be
confident the game the game is to rank
after other videos that people are
already watching on confidence
so what we want to do so seo still
matters but it's seo against other
people's videos so i'm searching to find
what are the videos that are popping up
and doing well so the first one is an ad
the second one is from charisma on
command you guys know that channel
charlie you guys fans i love charlie so
this video here how to radiate
confidence under pressure
saying could you make that video yeah
that's what you should make
i want zen to make a video called how to
radiate confidence under pressure he
doesn't have to watch his video but i
wanted to make that video as a title
because i want zayn's video to show up
after charlie's video
so do this for your own title whatever
you're thinking about i don't want zan
to make a video called how to be
confident i want zan to make a video
that says how to radiate confidence
under pressure a little bonus hack on
this is then you go to their channel
so if i go to charlie's channel
and then i click videos and then i sort
by most popular we can see charlie's got
5 million subs 5.3
anything that has more than 5.3 million
views on his video is helping him grow
his channel
anything less
is still a decent video but most videos
will underperform their sub count
most videos will get fewer views and
subscribers so any video on any channel
that has more views than subscribers is
really helping grow that channel
so the next challenge for zane would be
what other videos has this guy made that
he might be able to make a similar one
to the title i don't care about the
content
i want to rank after his video and then
zan's message
so if we look down here you know five
common habits that make people instantly
dislike you
you know maybe maybe that's confidence
maybe not you know how to avoid
embarrassing yourself in an argument
maybe maybe that's it maybe it's not you
go down here this is the one we talked
about this one here how to turn
awkwardness into confidence zayn could
you do that yes
that's the video
right this video got 9.7 million views
and he's got 5 million subs that chan
that video is helping charlie's channel
blow up zan should make his version of
it
now we started with how to have
confidence how to find confidence
whatever our initial thought was
this has given us a better way to make
better topics you still have to be
engaging ask great questions have a
powerful opinion you know the format 70
honest retention at one minute even on a
three hour video seventy percent of
audience potential at one minute is
still the goal because they will sit
there and watch
this is a better way to hack your way to
getting great topics for your video
and this is one example i can keep going
through charlie i can keep going through
other channels i can keep looking at
different search terms right the game
becomes how do i rank after other
people's video with a better video okay
one last tip
uh this is where i want you to record
okay
get this ready get your phone out record
get this down and make a huge difference
i'm gonna share an example so sean has
talked about
sharing your videos right newsletters
emails etc anytime you're going to be
sharing a video this is what i want you
to do i'm going to use sean's channel as
an example this is sean's main channel
right this is the think channel you guys
on you guys love the think media youtube
channel
let's go
okay
you're gonna go down to the uploads
playlist click play all okay we're gonna
click on this
at the top here there's omar we love
omar here it says ampersand list equals
this giant
thing
we all have our own
unique thing so your your channel will
have its own code we're gonna copy that
okay ctrl c that's all i did ctrl c here
at the top okay next i'm gonna go back
to i'm gonna go back to sean's channel
when you have a video
and lots of people might watch it we're
gonna put it in our newsletter list
we're gonna put it on our website we're
gonna put it in our email signature
we're gonna share it in our social media
bio right any time that many people
might see this video
we're gonna pick a video
so let's say
let's go find a recent video
uh
let's see so like this one how to make
youtube thumbnails cool sean's gonna do
a campaign and promote this video
normally what we would do is copy this
link and put it out right
here's our video we're not going to do
that we're going to go to the end and
we're going to paste in the thing that i
just copied paste okay here's what's
going to happen it's going to load the
video just like we promised but it puts
it inside the entire uploads of sean's
channel
so down the side here and if you can see
it yeah it says
1250 videos
so what's going to happen is they'll
watch this video and now we're
controlling where they go next
they're automatically going to another
video on our channel
you like that one
right so if i click if i we go to the
end of this video
okay it's going
it's going into the short and then after
the shorter go to the next one and i'll
go to the next one and go to the next
one so we're controlling automatically
what happens next here's the crazy thing
some people keep this open all day long
in their tap
like they play the video and then forget
about it and go eat lunch
or open up like have you ever done that
i've done that your video it's open in
the tab and you go do something else
they come back and all of a sudden
they've watched eight hours of think
media videos
so guess what they're gonna get
recommended a lot more think media
videos and even bigger than that is
other people who are like them will also
get recommended more think media videos
you like that one
cool
so anytime
anytime if you're sharing a video with
your friend don't worry about like it
doesn't matter but anytime it's going to
a lot of people newsletter email list
signature in your email uh website
embeds uh social media bios anytime it's
going to a bunch of people always put
that code it's going to be the same code
every time but it's unique to your
channel so that's shawn's code i just
wanted to show you how you could do it
for your channel you got the video so
don't come and ask me at the end
how do you do that thing again
i'm happy to answer questions i'm here
to serve i love the one-on-ones more
than being on being on stage makes me
nervous and gives me anxiety but it's
all just for the permission to
to help um and so stop being the hallway
i'll be around um
it took me a long time to get
comfortable in front of the camera guys
it took me a long time you saw the
journey
just keep going
and remember that you've got something
inside you that you want to share you
want to serve and you are making a
difference in people's lives please
keep going i love you thank you las
vegas if you want some more amazing
youtube advice check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there